Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
la dualité onde-corpuscule.
A première vue, il semblerait que l'on puisse
distinguer dans l'univers, deux types d'objets.
D'une part, certains objets se comportent
comme des points, avec une position bien définie,
qui peut se déplacer au cours du temps.
C'est par exemple le cas d'une pomme, d'une
voiture, ou encore d'une planète.
D'autre part, on peut également trouver des
phénomènes de propagation, qui n'ont cette
fois pas de position à proprement parler.
C'est ce que l'on appelle des ondes, comme
par exemple les vagues à la surface de l'eau.
Imaginons un mur, dans lequel seraient percées
deux fentes.
On place derrière ce mur un écran qui va être
capable de détecter les objets qui l'atteignent.
D'une part, si on lance les uns après les
autres des objets ponctuels, qui se comportent
comme des billes, alors on finira par obtenir
sur l'écran deux bandes bien distinctes,
qui correspondent aux deux fentes par lesquels
sont passés les objets.
D'autre part, si on émet maintenant des ondes,
comme par exemple des vagues dans l'eau, alors
en se propageant derrière les deux fentes,
elles vont se superposer.
En se superposant, les vagues vont soit s'ajouter
entre elles, pour former une plus grande vague,
soit s'annuler, pour former une vague plus
petite.
On observera alors sur l'écran une alternance
de franges lumineuses et sombres, qui correspondent
aux bosses et au creux formés par les vagues.
On obtient donc des résultats différents
en fonction du type d'objet.
Deux bandes bien distinctes dans le cas d'objets
ponctuels, comme des billes, des pommes ou
des planètes, et une alternance de bandes
d'interférences dans le cas où on envoie
des ondes, comme des vagues à la surface
de l'eau.
Cependant si l'on s'intéresse à des échelles
microscopiques, et notamment au monde des
particules, alors cette distinction entre
corpuscule et onde semble disparaître.
A l'échelle quantique, une particule n'a
pas de position bien définie.
En effet elle a uniquement plusieurs possibilités,
différentes positions qui lui sont disponibles,
avec des proportions qui peuvent varier.
Ce n'est qu'au moment de mesurer sa position,
que la particule va être forcée de choisir
au hasard une de ces possibilités.
Or il se trouve que plus une position intervient
au départ en grande proportion, plus il va
être probable que la particule choisisse
cet endroit en particulier
au moment où on va l'observer.
Ceci nous permet donc de tracer une courbe,
qui correspond à la probabilité d'observer
la particule en chaque position de l'espace.
Au moment où on va mesurer sa position, la
particule va de préférence choisir un endroit
où la courbe est haute, c'est à dire une
position qui est associée à une forte probabilité,
plutôt qu'un endroit où cette courbe est
basse, c'est à dire de faible probabilité.
Or cette courbe de probabilité n'est pas
fixe.
En effet, au cours du temps elle va évoluer,
et ce de façon
très similaire au mouvement d'une onde.
Reprenons alors notre expérience, mais avec
des particules cette fois-ci, et imaginons
que l'on puisse regarder sans que cela ne
les force à choisir une position.
Au départ, la particule que l'on envoie n'a
pas encore de position bien définie.
Sa courbe de probabilité va donc se propager
dans l'espace, et ce à la façon d'une onde.
Ainsi, comme les vagues dans l'eau, cette
courbe va passer à travers les deux fentes
en même temps, et se superposer avec elle-même
de l'autre côté du mur.
Elle va donc arriver jusqu'à l'écran, en
formant le même motif qu'aurait formé une onde,
une alternance de bosses et de creux.
Mais l'écran, qui a pour but de mesurer la
position de la particule, va alors la forcer
à choisir une position bien précise.
La particule qui jusqu'alors n'avait pas de
position, va donc choisir de se situer de
préférence à un endroit où la probabilité
est forte, c'est à dire au niveau d'une bosse
dans la courbe de probabilité.
On va alors observer un petit point sur l'écran,
à l'endroit qu'a choisi la particule.
Sur l'écran la particule prend donc l'apparence
d'un petit point, ce qui pourrait suggérer
qu'elle s'est comportée comme une petite
bille, et donc que les particules sont des
objets ponctuels.
Cependant si on continue d'en envoyer une
à une, les particules vont se regrouper au
niveau des bosses, car c'est là que la probabilité
est la plus forte.
On va alors finir par observer sur l'écran
le même motif que l'on obtenait en envoyant
des ondes.
Les particules se sont toutes regroupées
au niveau des bosses,
et ainsi ont formé ensemble ce motif.
Les particules qui composent notre
univers ne sont donc ni des corpuscules, ni des ondes.
Elles peuvent parfois présenter des propriétés
qui font penser à des objets ponctuels, et
parfois des propriétés qui font penser aux
ondes.
Cette dualité onde / corpuscule qui règne
au sein du monde quantique est due au fait
qu'une particule, avant qu'on l'observe, est
décrite par une courbe de probabilité, et
que cette courbe de probabilité, elle, se
propage et évolue dans le temps,
comme une onde.